all right welcome to another edition to
a beginner breakdown I am your host Mike
hover and today we'll be going over the
games of Eric hotner he was a very
novice beginner not too long ago but
he's been coming up to the club playing
in the Friday action quads playing in
tournaments whenever he can and he also
takes in the ladder competition so these
are three games from the ladder he's
raised his rating about 300 points in
the last few months just by playing a
lot and here we go in this first game he
has white against dr. Eden alright so he
starts out you for all right black
counters with E 5 very standard stuff
brings out the knight to f3 to attack
the IE pawn so black counters Knight to
c6 there protect it and now white plays
Bishop to c4 aiming at this f7 square ok
and now black makes a mistake and you're
probably gonna say Mike this Knight f6
is not a mistake but it is a mistake if
you're a beginner and you don't know the
theory it's a mistake alright because it
allows night this night to play g5 so if
you were one of my students and you play
them move Knight to f6 I would be very
very angry yeah okay so try not to play
Knight f6 in this position because it
allows white to go into the Spry liver
attack the three moves you should be
thinking about in this position which
you probably see very often do you think
that's f6 no no don't play f6 in this
position play Bishop to c5 okay Bishop
to e7 or even h6 the move of h6 I mean
it looks kind of funny but now not
thinking hop to g5
and also you don't have to worry about
that back road checkmate later on in the
game okay so after Bishop c4 those are
the three moves you should be thinking
about now the move Knight f6 if you know
the theory you could play it but since
you don't know the theory I would not
play it so now you just let them play
Knight to g5 and now you're in a lot of
trouble here okay you don't want to be
in a lot of trouble all right so now
what's the only move black can make to
stop my knight or my bishop from coming
in and and yeah and getting all the pain
on you yes all right black plays the
move
d5 CR cuts the alright we're giving out
candy tonight so sorry for the players
at home just if you get the right answer
just buy yourself a bag and eat one if
you get the right answer okay all right
but d5 it cuts off the connection
between the bishop and f7 okay so now
white takes the pawn okay remember we
don't want to take with the bishop cuz
white is on the attack when we're on the
attack we don't want to trade pieces
right so we take with the pawn and so it
took something to mind I'm gonna take it
back
Knight takes d5 oh wait and now if
you're brave and you're strong you want
to go into the fried liver attack so
Keith this is your chance to get a get a
piece of candy what would you play to go
into the fried liver attack here have
you seen this it's a sacrifice Jim how
do you go into the fried liver attack
Peter
take the pawn Knight takes up seven
forking the Queen and the rook obviously
the king can take all right because
Kings can capture unprotected pieces
all right so King no can you can okay
that's too easy
all right so King takes f7 all right so
this Knight is in a pin and we're down a
piece so we want to try to get this
Knight back how would we go about
attacking this Knight here remember we
don't want to capture pin pieces we want
to attack them
Queen to f3 check all right Keith is on
the board all right good job Keith
all right so Queen f3 check so the King
could be really we can go back home
where he thinks he's safe but then we
would take the knight with our Bishop
because we don't want to trade Queens in
this position so we take with the bishop
and now we're threatening checkmate
Queen to F so if he plays a random move
Queen to f7 checkmate game over all
right so that didn't last long
all right so so he decides he's going to
march the King closer to all our
attacking pieces not good idea we'd
rather be safe in a castle all right so
now we have two players attacking the
knight but he's got two defenders so we
don't want to take the knight here okay
we want to keep attacking this pin piece
so everybody at home knows the answer
Knight to c3 all right getting another
attacker
so now black has a couple different ways
you can play you can play Knight back to
e7 okay and then white would castle he
would get another defender here then we
swing our rook over and now we have
another attacker of the pawn and
eventually we'll get something in like
d4 just attack the pin piece and black
is just going to fold okay you can't
take the
pressure okay but dr. Ian decides not to
play that way he decides to defend it
and attack night to be for notice that's
the only night they can go to be for if
I try to put that night it's Chuck okay
so this is the only night that I go to
be for if I was playing white in this
position I would just Castle okay but
he's like I don't even care alright
you're attacking see - who cares I don't
even know what he plays he plays a a
three get out of here okay not
recommended all right
Castle get safe okay so then he's like
alright Jack King here all right so so
white once black to take his rook cuz he
thinks he's gonna get all these good
checks or or maybe discovery or
something good okay so now blacks
thinking after check why is he letting
me do all this why is he just giving me
a rook for free so he decides I'm not
gonna take the rook all right but you
know you're down so much or well I mean
actually this position black is up a
piece I mean you're already copped your
knight down here you might as well just
go for it and I mean black may still
have the advantage here and steady
I guess he gets a little scared of the
attack so he decided all me I gotta do
something about this so so what how
would how do you think he defends this
night here what would be the best way to
defend the knight here any c6 alright
good good job Jim so you get Milky Way
good alright c6 alright but but now he's
like okay thanks for the night alright
so so what doctor you really should have
thought about was in this position okay
why I could just go back to e7 and
protect and then play c6 after castle
right
okay our if I'm going to go down to be
four and threatened check and win your
Brook and then I just let you do it
right you got to just go for it then and
just say do your best right do or do
your worst hopefully so I win the game
but if he if you don't take that you
just gave him a night for free okay and
now white is just crushing black and and
black isn't gonna last much longer so
everybody understand that
all right so now it's white to move or
actually it's black to move after king
takes so he brings his Bishop out that
really didn't do anything to to help him
out with this situation but it did
activate his rook all right so now he
plays d4 attacks the bishop and attacks
the pawn all right so rook to f8 attacks
the Queen and now white gets excited
because what what are you trying to look
for in chess captures and checks for
seen moves captures and checks okay
obviously we can capture the rook but
that's no good we get captured the
bishop but that's no good so and
obviously we don't want to capture a pin
piece right no reason to it
okay so then we see a chuck Queen to g4
check all right sounds good to me King
here guess what
I see another check might as well play
it boom all right rook up seven guess
what I see another check all right what
do things are really good check in this
position Queen Bishop to g5 alright this
Queen's already doing a lot Bishop g5
fork
our skewer or whatever you want to call
it good move how about and now he just
gives up he's like oh I give up
oh you're too good too good all right
how would he
how would he go about closing the deal
here cuz I don't know Queen takes King
takes Bishop takes it looks like you're
you're up a little bit but it's all good
you get up a rook here so now Eric plays
a black against a 1700 Matt Flynn okay
here we go so white plays d4 file by d6
d4 Knight f6 white protects the e pawn
with Knight to c3 g6 and now Bishop to
g5 allowing h6 so Bishop the g7 he
decides not to punish white for his
mistake
so Queen to d2 so he's just screaming
like play h6 and break up my battery
here okay alright so he does and he
plays c5 okay you can learn something
from this to around it so in this
position alright so obviously white
could play pawn takes pawn takes Queen
takes check King takes but now white
won't have any kind of checkmate ideas
okay and when he plays the perk we want
to checkmate him right okay so in this
position we want to play d5 alright and
that whenever he tries to make a break
either with E 5 or c5 we want to play d5
and that cuts out the center alright
that way he'll have no counter play in
the center and we can attack on the
wings okay and then this Bishop after we
play the move f3 eventually let's say
plays
there his bishop has nowhere to go okay
and we're crushing him okay makes sense
but instead he just he just decides to
defend it Knight f3 not good all right
so now castles black obviously needs to
take this pawn so Bishop the c-4 pins
the pawn and now guess who got the play
now the bishop okay because the Knights
on f3 instead of a pawn it gives a
bishop something to do okay
we could have just made that bishop week
forever if our pawn was on f3 okay but
now he's got something to do so
obviously after Bishop to h6 he'll take
the knight all right because that Bishop
wasn't doing much so now if you're
playing white what should you do he just
took my knight make it simple right he
just took my piece I'll take it a lot of
beginners try to make things complicated
unnecessarily right all right he took
your knight just take it back okay but
he decides he'll take here which allows
black to do what's called an intermezzo
okay like he wants to take this but he
can make a move in between that's
actually good when white tried to enter
me so it was no good he was expecting
King takes and then pawn takes okay but
after it takes and takes he'll take this
pawn okay so now I don't want to lose my
rook so I play rook to g1 King takes
rook takes okay and now white is down a
pawn now a lot of people at home might
say all white has adequate compensation
for that pun because this G file is open
but
this black pawn is pretty strong it's
protected well three times so we'll have
to make them pay for that okay so now
being down a pawn White's gonna have to
prove that it's worth having this G file
open all right so now he takes Queen
takes nights in a pin so I have to watch
out for that knight c6 attacks the Queen
Queen to e3 gets it back on this
diagonal all right a six so so now why
it's got to be thinking why did he do
that right so he wants to play B 5 B 4
and get a pawn push on
all right so white besides I don't care
I'm gonna castle right into the danger
okay so after b5 Bishop b3 and it turns
out he's pretty safe in this castle so
black goes to e5 eyeing the c-4 square
so white attacks it with f4 so black
goes there so now this Bishop really
doesn't have much going on for it my
Queens attacks though we might as well
just take take back and now it's White's
turn okay so now White has a couple
different moves you should be
considering here what do you think so
notice this this pawn isn't a pin this
pawn is in a pin rook Queen okay so
let's start attacking those pin pieces
so right b5 all right so now the Knights
gotta move somewhere so he goes h5 okay
so white could just press on right so he
made you attack this one pin piece you
can just attack another okay but instead
he decides I'm just gonna take the point
so he takes back now keep in mind white
is down a pawn here right so
if he gets his pawn back there just even
so maybe he thought he doesn't have a I
wait I would just keep attacking this
pawn okay but instead he decides I can
win this pawn back right now so I'm
going to alright so sees a check so he
plays a check check Queen to f6 and now
no matter what black is going to trade
Queens if white takes this pawn how does
black force a Queen trade here f4 very
good Queen takes up 4 check ok if he
takes this way guess what I'm just gonna
take your queen okay I'm joking yeah
yeah I was getting to it I was kidding
yeah so I so yeah he's it'll be like
really smart they'll just take check and
then we're gonna put get it all right so
he's like oh I don't want you to take up
for so he's just like Queen takes Chuck
so Knight takes up sexy around and then
rook takes d6 now we're in an endgame
okay so now things have drastically
changed alright so when things have
drastically changed in a position like
this we need to take a deep breath and
just start doing some Counting here okay
and count what's on the board not what's
off of it okay so so if I was playing
white or black I would be like okay we
each have five pawns which have rooks we
each have a knight okay how hard is it
my kings and a pen you know my rooks are
pretty much defenders all right so I
have to get them activated okay and
maybe I'm not really that afraid of f5
okay so and my pawns are pretty junky
all right so you have to take stock of
the position and realize what's going on
so he decides I'm gonna activate my rook
all right fair enough all right he had
to do something I mean work the c8
pretty passive so so maybe work that you
won't be 8 is the best move all right so
so now he's like see how White has two
isolated pawns and so does black but he
decides I'm gonna get rid of mine right
away get rid of your weaknesses that was
good
why he probably sat back and identified
his weakness I'm like okay I'll get rid
of me
all right so Jack who loves that check
for black who thinks Wow black is good
he's like he's checking me he's just
crushing now booboo that check all right
even though it's check it doesn't mean
it's good now unfortunately he'll stew
and say oh man I'm in check I better put
my knight back on d1 and get out of the
check don't play don't don't pin your
own pieces okay I mean like don't hit
yourself don't pin your pieces okay
you could just play King to d2 and now
you've got an active King and he's
threatening the rook all of a sudden
okay so you see that select I mean I
know it's Czech and almost have to
resist playing a check but it just helps
white oh okay so now rook here attacks
the pawn all right so pawn takes black
takes toward the center here all right
so now rook the c6 attacks the pawn so
he decides I better defend it that was
good so now trying to remove the
defender try to get this rook off the
fourth-ranked so we can take the pawn
rook the g4 so now why could take here
and remove the defender but check
so now black all of a sudden has to past
ponds pretty scary right so so don't go
into this variation okay makes sense
because guess what you're going to get
this pond no matter what I mean it's
going to be really tough for him to
defend it it's going to be pretty much
it's going to be easier for you to
defend this pond then that him defending
this point okay so we don't want to
trade one-to-one because it's going to
be so much easier for us to get it so so
knowing that we play rook to f2 so now
we have two guys piling on this knight
on f6 okay all right so what do you
think black plays cuz I have no idea
what would he play so two guys are
coming down and attacking your knight
it's pretty scary any ideas from the
audience because I don't know I don't
know what do you think how would you
defend the night at home you move it
yeah all right you just check them again
okay
all right rook the e6 I work the e8
check all right so but now oh so when he
plays King to f3 now the rook is no
longer attacking the knight all right so
now we're four it keeps it on the
fourth-ranked alright so now I bet
people think they see a tactic here cuz
I think I see a tactic but I really
really don't so so I I slammed King to
g3 I mean I slam it look at what I just
did I attacked the rook an undefended
piece and a discovered attack on the
night
all right let's just let's just let's
let's let's do my thing first what does
black play to stop this right let's
black them oh so night check lose so so
that's a way to get out of it maybe
maybe yeah I guess I take take and then
I eat all your pawns
alright so that's one way to get out of
it
see if the computer has something a
little bit better
now it likes just taking that appears
dumb alright so forget the computer
alright so so what I was looking at is
if I play on King to g3 so Knight to e4
seems to work or you can just check all
right and then repeat the position all
right but but yeah the Jonathan's like
oh I see a tactic that's the exactly
alright so I have two rook the h4 let's
see if it works
so he's like rook takes f6 and now I
really am threatening King to g3 check
all right and it looks like it's gonna
work because
Oh devastation devastation it doesn't
work because the king can can be the
lone defender okay but it was a good try
though it's such a good try
so sometimes you think there's so many
tactics and chess but they just aren't
any so it's a bummer isn't it it's a
bummer you think you have everything
going for you and yet so so they did the
move that I suggested then I would have
slammed but it gives it 0.000 because he
just plays check and uh everything's
good so so he's like all right there's
no tactics I'm just gonna take your pawn
and I got an a pawn and I'm just gonna
beat you like that okay so sometimes
simplicity is the best all right so he
just puts his piece where uh you know he
can take it so he does okay I'll take it
so he takes a kind of a curious where he
takes with the rook because he thinks
I'm gonna I'm gonna check you so bad
then I'm gonna win this rook
so rook here rook check King to g2 and
now black decides unfortunately to go
into a losing endgame here I mean he's
got to see how am I gonna stop 84 85 86
87 88 and you're like Mike that's 1 2 3
4 5 moves
I got like it don't worry I'll figure it
out I got plenty of time to figure it
out but but do you and will that check
that that helped a lot all right so rook
over and now he's like okay stop it I
dare you stop it well I got my own past
pawn all right but notice the difference
my King can stop it your King nowhere to
be found
hey v he's going he's going I'm not
joking 8600 okay well good luck ever
again to a7 Oh
check King over and I a seven so I'm one
square away that didn't really take too
much time right I'm so close I'm so
close now so now black besides the high
from any kind of check okay but now we
get h4 check so King back to f6 so we
don't well yeah why why trade this pawn
for that right so he decided to be funny
the way he gets a pastor so b4 so black
doesn't even know about Uncle sense so
he plays check King up this is not
checkmate unfortunately so King over and
now just keep pushing that beep on and
game's over this last game even though
it doesn't take much time it's the
importance of when you have a chance to
win a game if you have a chance for a
tactic you got a strike ok you don't
want to be messing around ok because the
tactics might not last very long so in
this game
Eric has the white pieces again we get
flip the board and white plays efore c5
so this is the Sicilian Knight up 3d6
allowing the check but it's not very
good so white plays c3 going into the c3
Sicilian Knight f6 attacks the pawn so
white thinks he's like really good and
he's like I guess he probably saw this
somebody showed it to him so he's like I
just played my Bishop to e2 and IA like
so fancy so he's hoping that black takes
e4 ok why is that just a double double
double questionable right everybody's
gonna get a piece of candy
all right so hopefully a home you'll get
up here's candy for this - all right so
why it's not an idiot he didn't just
give us pawn up for nothing
look this is how tactics arise in chess
you have a piece you know on in your
territory undefended so if we can attack
this and possibly a very very strong
piece and we can somehow freeze the
piece we can win so we can all shout it
out so we need to a4 check
congratulations everybody
hey fast pita and Jim the only one John
didn't get it good day for a check all
right so Queen to a Ford check all right
so so black I guess saw it so he's like
all right East six so white castle's
Bishop e7 so black understands they
can't take the pawn so he'll just
develop normally so so white decided
he'd be really cool and trick them but
now his Bishop is on e2 not doing squat
okay so now it plays d5 so black should
just take it which he does Knight takes
and now black I castle and it's move
seven so both both are playing pretty
strong right so far so good
so white plays d4 so all we have to do
is calculate our captures here so really
good trade you know this winged pawn
obviously we're not training it for a
center pond because pawn takes and then
he gets it back but look at what we just
did we gave him an isolated D pawn so
when the pawns are isolated you know no
pawns can protect them now we can just
pile up and attack this pawn eventually
he'll probably have to push it or
something by
well we don't want to play Knight to c6
here but we have all day to try and
attack it you know rook d8 and we got a
lot of different ways to attack okay so
that's what I would do I would give him
a weakness and an isolated point is a
weakness all right but unfortunately
Black has other ideas he plays Queen to
c7 right away hoping that he takes the
pawn so I just got your night buddy
all right so white decides not to
voluntarily remove the defender and now
he plays a tactic alright Bishop Knight
Queen all in the same Lane scary
so if black would skip a move like play
a six
what would we play as white here and you
very good
we went play Knight takes pawn or
nothing Knight to g6 once it protects
the bishop and after the Queen moves we
take the rope sound good alright so so
he's like all right I got to get out of
this diagonal so Queen to b6 attacking
the pawn now the computer says you know
play Knight to c4 you know it's kind of
cool it attacks my Queen and protects
the pawn but I mean you kind of like
your knight here I mean I do so forget
that so plays b3 here have just pawn
protect pawn that way nobody's got a got
a really babysat the pawn here just a
pawn okay alright so now rook to d8 all
right so now this pawn is in a pin
alright but I guess it could actually
take here and then if Rick takes pawn
takes but we don't want to do that we
don't want to do that so so if I was
white I probably just get out of there
maybe with Queen to c2 or something well
when you got to be careful because he's
got a lot of attackers on here so he
decides Bishop to e3 so now the bishop
and queen are all in alignment here
all right so he goes back to c7 so do
you think he just plays back here no he
plays a queen - see - but look at what
happened when he played Queen to c2 so
so if you're really paying attention now
at home right all right you got to be
looking at what's all in the same files
okay like Oh me and I wanted to get off
this file because the rooks on that file
so I go here but we'll look at what's on
that file the Queen so if somehow we get
rid of these pawns
guess what the Queen's would be
attacking each other okay so now all you
have to do is try to try to clear out
the file and then Queen takes Queen
right so how would we do that John
banking on you we want to clear the C
file how would we clear the C file so
well we play clear the C file like if
these two pawns get off the C file Queen
can come down and take the Queen right
right
so what moves do you think we should
make try to clear it off
how about pawn takes pawn okay yeah like
what it's defended twice so if we take
this way our dream came true right and
we get our do we get the Queen but it's
like I just take with the bishop
horrible so then then how do we how do
we make them pay
yes just take it right because the pawns
in a pin and boom tactic
okay so Queen to c2 I just put it put my
Queen Randall aligned nope so pawn takes
pawn alright so he sees shucks my
Knights under attack I can't take this
way cuz Brooke would take so I just play
Bishop to f4 so blacks leg off he
protected the night shucks
well I got nothing so this is when you
got a strike in chess all right so the
Queen knight in a bishop this is the
action diagonal now if only I could put
something else on this action diagonal
like a crush them like my bishop right
Bishop the d6 alright and now obviously
still can't take the pawn and he can't
protect this knight in any way shape or
form and if he tries Knight to d3 or
something we take Knight takes Queen
takes okay we get two pieces for one
sound good it sounds good to me right
and if he moves the bishop will just
obviously take the knight right
all right so those are tactics and we
got to see them attacking through an
x-ray and steady it's like well I'll
just take that pawn that's good so so if
you were playing white let's take a vote
we cuz we got to take take it back right
we have to take it back okay so will we
take back with the knight or we're going
to take back with the queen let's take a
show of hands who wants us to take with
the Queen
we have any takers for the Queen all
right we got one we've got the the
producer Ben Simon with the Queen and
now now Jim is a given in the peer
pressure he didn't want to be the only
one was an apple yeah - all right so
they're both right so when we take with
the night what did we just do to
ourselves we just picked up ourselves
again and so so now what are we supposed
to do - pin pieces all right so what's
black gonna play attack the pin piece
Bishop before we have better better than
Bishop to b4 what could be better than
Bishop to b4 Knight to d5 fork all right
now the computer is like oh just take it
and lose your queen cuz that's the best
you got computers playing hope chess
because Knight takes check where is
white just hoping black goes like please
go there go to h8 yeah yeah and say your
king looks pretty safe in the corner
buddy and there's like oh yeah oh you
know thanks ooh and then and then what
it was white play to win the game here
Knight takes eight seven f7 checkmate
right all right so the computer is even
in the Hope Chest at this point because
its position so bad okay so Knight to d5
obviously if we play Bishop the d2 we
hang our knight make sense
all right so but that's what everybody
wanted so he plays it all right so so
not good not good so so if you have a
guest do you think blacks gonna punish
white for having this piece and a pin
absolutely not
a six okay let's not punish this guy
all right so you laugh but remember when
you have these these ideas and chest
pins got to do it okay
so Bishop the f3 doesn't want them to
play b5 that would be catastrophe rate
so so Knight to d7 Knight takes so now
you could take the bishop art takes the
knight rook d1 attacks the Queen Queen
e8 takes Queen takes rook to d1 Queen
back and night they for why not
alright he's threatening threatening the
big night the b6 so he doesn't even one
yeah not going to be sick so he plays
Knight to d7 okay so this Bishop will
never get to move probably all right so
Bishop to c7 all right just so you can
put a guy on these things it's probably
a good good as ideas Annie
so now Queen to d3 and yeah it without
these tactics the game doesn't look as
interesting now Bishop f6 oh and then
there's a tactic probably what I missed
it the bishop the lonely lonely Bishop
is just overloaded now he's protecting
the knight and the bishop and the pawn
so Bishop takes Bishop takes Queen takes
he decides not to take decides to put
his fish up there first and now he gets
the fork in and protects so Queen takes
Knight takes and rook over and he just
lets them take and SS pawns and now you
notice bishop of opposite colors always
a draw okay so takes takes and draw all
right always going to be a draw
you could have some funny positions if I
can - I've tried one more funny position
here alright it looks like he's got two
pawns - none right he could just play
here and there's nothing he can do you
see that it just doesn't matter as long
as he gets his King on the same color
square of his Bishop alright not of the
same color because if he goes here then
checks can happen and and he can remove
them or you can take three bishops right
but you see you want you want to get
your King on the same squares your
Bishop and then have the other bishop
stop these pawns and there's nothing you
can do makes sense
all right so you learn something
Thanks all right well thank you all for
coming thank you to Eric Hosmer for
showing his his games and it's another
edition of beginner breakdown